May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you. I have come back to you
again. I hope you liked the previous lessons. There were no
problems. Of course, as I
promised you and told you, any problems or needs you face, please
send me a message. And, God willing, I will respond to you
as much as I can. With my
knowledge of the previous session, we have finished up to the
module manager part.  We made a module in it. What do you
think about the case of Egypt? I was looking for something in the article
and this was the shape of our newspaper as we see the form. It also still
needs some
modifications and additions. This is a little. I
added it with you. Ok, we will come back again and try to add a
new module as we think the modules
are.  The parts that are added here and these parts in
their name are Yuzir One Anin and they are placed in. When
adding the module, we will see together. We will go to the
module manager from here. After that, we will go to New and
the relationships of our modules. We will add, for example, a
random image and do the following. It will tell you to write the
name of the module you want to name first.
Yes, of course, I haven't uploaded any pictures yet. Choose where his position
will be and we will find in the
ranking part and this part of the ranking because the chosen one, I
turned and turned, of course, is the left. We will find in
the items, Okay, it will tell you where the position of this item of this module in the turn
will be,
above the dot or above the poll, of course.  We will
leave it in the banner so that it remains a
little different. The banner here is, of course, it is here. It is calculated
on the basis that this template is not parsed. So the RT is
here for him and the RT is different for him. The
RT is supposed to be here and the RT is here. Okay. He tells you that you want to
remain registered. Ok, it will appear publicly for all people.
Does your response appear in parts?  Also, where should we
choose from here? There is a problem. Also,
information about the model. The type of image you
want to post. It will be of a type. It is
only AGBG or other. We can add the images folder and notice
that the main folder for the images is Eggs
Slash Stores. Ok, can I write it myself?
Big Slash Stores, but the problem here is that
I haven't added pictures to this folder
yet. It now tells you the path to the folder. Take the pictures from it and
show them to you. Okay, Nasib,
why now? What is the link that anyone who clicks on the
image will be transferred to? We choose, for example,
Art.com. The display is for images in pixels.  Can we make it 150
x 150, for example, other information, there is no good.
Now we have Eggs Slush Stores. It is ok. We can
save and see or apply. Of course, you need to
make an application to make sure that everything is
perfect. After that, you can save. The application has been applied. Of course it is
different from saving if you remain on the same page.
Okay, let's go back to making a sample and see what form is
in front of us. We will notice that it is today's caricature and we
do not have any pictures because I did not upload pictures in the
required folder. Okay, I made another folder with the
name Omar
inside Folder Ages, and it contains some pictures. Okay, how did I make this folder? I will
explain to you now that we make an application and see if we
can refresh it.  We will notice that an image is starting to appear,
and if we click on it, we will notice that the link is
now visible in front of us. We click on it. It will change us to the place
we want to go back again. We will do everything we
refresh. Note that the images change. This is the one
I was uploading. Ok, now I want to make a
folder like you. How did you do the folder?  This folder, of course, is an
Image Slash Read image. Ok, we will
first go to our CPanel, and then we will
go to our File Manager, which was
uploaded in Joomla magazine. After that, we will go to Joomla, and
after that we will go to the Images path
as we were thinking, and we will find in the name folder.  This is
Stores, which was the obligatory option. Or
can we create a new folder? Ok, now I want to make
pictures or caricatures or something else. What will
I do? The first thing I will do is make a new folder with the name of what I
want, for example, caricatures or something else. We will name it, for example, Egypt, and create a new
folder. Okay, no
problem. We will find the folder visible.  In front of us, okay, I will open the
folder and upload the pictures that I
want to upload, make a frame, and start looking for the
pictures where to put them. After that, I will start uploading, and I will start making an
automatic frame, as we see
this, and the pictures will be uploaded and we will
find the pictures are available with us. After that, I will go back to our newspaper again and change the path to Omar.  For
example, I will leave it as “Egypt” as I made the
new folder, made an application, and refreshed so that I can see
the image that I uploaded. We will notice that the image that I uploaded is here. Of course,
whenever I freshen it, I will not find another image because
I did not
make many images or uploaded such an image. We can
go again also.  And we upload another image. We might know
about this image, and I wanted to upload it and it starts to
upload as
we see. This is also the case for the image. Of course, we are supposed to add as many images as we want. We can add it to a
compressed file and start decompressing it. Of course, we knew
how to decompress
after a few images were lost.  I will try to do a refresh and see
what happens. I will do a refresh. We will notice that the pictures
change according to the picture that I uploaded.
All of this was as simple as saving. That's it. We made the removal
of today's cartoon.
Of course, this is not a cartoon. We can also add something
new. We can also do a member login
if we make members.  When we know this
and do the
following, choose its place, for example, a cell in the
RT. Also, its place will be above the cricket or
below it as it is located like this. If we want to make a
text before and a half after, choose the materials that appear
in it only. This conversion is all very easy
when reading, there is no problem anymore.  This is how we
save, we must create a title, of course, why, as
we know how to log in to the newspaper, for example,
we save and go back
and see how it looks like this. How will we do a refresh? We will notice in the login that we will go back and close it and see for us any other additions that we
can add. Newest. Most read topics.
Most read topics. We can click on them.  Instead of the following, the
most read articles. Ok, I want to see where they
are, sir. In the light in the RT, in a
specific place, we can choose as it is. I want it to be
above or below the mile. Menu. Let it remain like this. It will be
before the mile. Menu. And the number of articles that want to
appear, how many times. For example, let three articles remain
edited.  We save and refresh to see what it looks like. We will
notice that the most read articles appear
in front of us like this. Ok, we want to
add something else to the right. It remains new and we see the login. The advertisement banner. In each of course, something like this. We add something
new. For example, we add the latest news. We
do the following and see if we do the latest
news and choose a number.  Articles, for example, let us make them
three articles and choose the order. The order depends on
whether the writer is anyone, not the added person, or someone who modified
it, or something else. We count it as we want to make it.
For example, this time in the review, we kept saving and
refreshing to see if it looks like the latest news. We have new
topics that we
made like this.  S three and three,
very simple, there is no problem. Notice that he
said hello to my name so that I can log
in very simply. We have finished the modules
and understood them well. Of course, this newspaper is
just an experimental thing so that you
can understand it after we have finished the modules. For example, I will find the picture in front of me and I want to
write, for example, on it
the name of our newspaper.  Or our magazine, what will I
do? The first thing I will do is right-click and
see the path of this image. Where will we notice the path of the
image? We will see Templates and the name of the blog, and then Imags, and then after that the logo. Ok, how will I go to these things? I will go to the Facebook page. What will I do? I will go
to the templet. After that, enter the name of the person.  He
was there, and then we go to Eggs, and we were
lucky to see the picture of Logo that was in
front of us. We right-click and download it. He will tell
you to download it. We say to him, “Yes, okay.”
After that, what should I do? I will open my
Photoshop program or any drawing program and download
my picture and make it bigger like this, as we
see.  After that, I simply erase
the name I want to write with the brush and write what I
want. I use the writing tool and
very simply show that my writing is good.
After that, I write the name of my newspaper, or for example I
will write it as a portal and leave it above that in a
large font as we see it, and
choose Start News as shown.  We see
this. We can make the font a little smaller.
Of course, this is a preliminary form. This is a quick thing. Just to
show you how the process goes, I
choose any quick style for him, and this is also any
quick style. The process will simply be finished, and
after that I make a sword for him. Of course, I have to sword him
in the same way I used to take him.  It
was in GIF or GIF format. I will make it, for example, Pink format.
After that, I simply change it again and
make a sword. The image will appear with me normally.
After that, I will go to the C-Panel. After that, go to the
place where the image was and create an upload. I will
upload a letter to it. Of course, the same image that
was there is
still there.  On the disktop, the picture was called
Loo Be Angie. Notice that Andy uploads the picture with me. I
simply go and do a search and see where the picture is.
Notice that of course, I am going to take this sentence and undo it and take this and
edit it and
leave it. After that, I will go and stay on my sentence and
make feathers and see what will be done.  We will notice that the name of
the newspaper, as we see it, has changed in the
Start News portal. Of course, we can change this,
enlarge the space, or write as we
want, and we can control any template we have through,
of course, the template, as I told you. We will also see its location again, plus
confirmation. I will mark the first thing in the
new sentence.  Ours, and I look around and find myself in a folder
called Images, and this is what will contain the image
that we will upload, or anywhere, and a folder called Templet. This is where
all the templates will remain, and each template will
contain its own images, for example, its own images, and
I will know the path to the image and start
uploading it in this place very simply. This was the lesson.
This is for today. I hope, God willing, there
will be no problems with us. It is possible that some
people do not like the look of the template and want to
change it. Of course, I told you how to change the templates. We
will first go to the Add-ons or
Template Manager, Add-ons, and after that, the
Template Manager, and we will remain with the Template Manager. We choose  A
new template. We choose, for example, this template, make it the
default, and do a refresh. We
will find our template changed, and it is very simple. As I told you, we want to change the logo and change any
image. We will change it.
Right-click on it. Ok, for example, this image. Right-click does
not show my image. I mean, I make
the image placed on top of the SCS merge. What should I do?  You will
decide the topic according to the name of the template,
meaning, for example, the name of the template is G.E. As we
see, I will go to the CPanel and go to my sentence as well. After that, the sentence template is
opened, and after that I go to the template and see
what the name of the template is. This is the name of its template, and I
fear for the password.  Also, most likely,
the name of the image above this will be the name of the
logo. I want to make sure that it is the name of the logo. I will
know how to notice this on it. Right-click on it and do a view. You will notice that this is the image that
you want to right-click and download
to it, and after that you start writing on it as you like.
We are familiar with Photoshop or any
writing program. I hope today’s lesson will be easy and there will be no
problem. Thank you and sorry if it took
me a long time. Don’t forget to Subscribe to the channel and like and share so
that everyone
can benefit. Don’t
forget to Subscribe to the channel and Like and
Share so that everyone
can benefit.